PASS MY TIME. ALRIGHT. WHICH
DOESN'T BELONG IN. WHY COACHES
ON THE HOT SEAT,
MATT NEGIAH THE BEARS. ZACK
TAYLOR THE BENGALS. KLIFF
KINGSBURY, THE CARDINALS WHICH
DOESN'T BELONG AND WHY I
WISH THAT MET NAGY.
WAS ON THE HOT SEAT, BUT I
DON'T THINK HE IS. I HONESTLY
DON'T, I THINK HE DOESN'T
BELONG IN THIS GROUP.
I THINK KLIFF KINGSBURY IS ON
THE HOT SEAT. I THINK ZACH
TAYLOR, YOU KNOW, YOU COULD
MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO WIN RIGHT NOW. BUT
IT ALSO YOU CAN SEE THE
BANGLES SAYING, OKAY, WE HAVE
OUR FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK AND
JOE BOROUGH. IF THEY DON'T
WIN, IF YOU GET THE BENGALS
WERE FRISKY. LAST YEAR. IF
THEY DON'T, MAYBE TAKE A STEP
FORWARD
FROM FRISKY TO, YOU
KNOW, DECENT THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE A SIGN THAT LIKE,
HEY, WE HE'S NOT WORKING OUT
MATT NAGIN.
SHE HAS A ROOKIE QUARTERBACK
WHO
WAS DRAFTED IN THE FIRST
ROUND. THEY GOT ANOTHER SHOT
AT IT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER
KIND OF WHAT THE BEAR IS LONG.
AS JUSTIN FEELS IN. COME ON
THE FIELD AND
LOOK TERRIBLE.
I THINK HE KEEPS HIS JOB. NO
MATTER WHAT AND KLIFF
KINGSBURY
KLIFF KINGSBURY. I THINK WE'LL
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF THE HEAT
THIS YEAR. I REALLY DO
BECAUSE THEY, THEY PUT SOME
INVESTMENT IN THE DEFENSE
DEANDRE HOPKINS.
HE'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE GUY
WHO'S TAKING
KYLER MARIE TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I THINK IF THAT
CARDINALS. TEAM DOESN'T TAKE
THE NEXT STEP.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A WARM SEAT
FOR KLIFF KINGSBURY.
NOW, A WEEK AGO, YOU SAID THAT
THE BEARS QUITE POSSIBLY WOULD
FIRE MATT NAGY. EVEN THOUGH
THE SELECTION OF JUSTIN
FIELDS, PRESUMABLY GIVES HIM
AND RYAN PASTE, TWO MORE YEARS
BECAUSE THE BEARS ARE THE
BEARS AND THEY WOULD
GO AHEAD AND CREATE
TOTAL DYSFUNCTION BY FIRING
NAGY AND BRINGING, IN A COACH
WHO MAYBE NEVER WOULD HAVE
DRAFTED,
JUST IN FIELDS IN A MILLION
YEARS, I'M GOING TO AGREE WITH
YOU ON
KINGSBURG. I THINK THE SEAT
UNDER KINGSBURY IS HARDER THAN
WE REALIZE
THE TIME IS NOW FOR THIS TEAM
TO MAKE IT TO THE PLAYOFFS, I
REALLY DO THINK IT'S
PLAYOFFS OR OUT.
FOR KINGSBURY. THEY GO FIND
SOMEONE WHO WILL SPECIFICALLY
CONSTRUCT AN OFFENSE TO GET
THE MOST OUT OF CALAMARI GOING
FORWARD. IF IT DOESN'T WORK
THIS YEAR, IN ARIZONA, THE
BEARS DIVISION, OPPONENTS
VIKINGS PACKERS LIONS WHICH
DOESN'T BELONG
AND WHY
I MEAN, THE PACKERS DON'T
BELONG IN THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THEY'VE OWNED THE NFC
NORTH. AND SO
I WOULD, YOU KNOW, THE
VIKINGS LIONS AND BEARS
ARE KIND OF IN THEIR OWN CLASS
AND THE PACKERS ARE ABOVE IT
WHICH STINKS TO SAY, BUT
IT'S THE TRUTH, RIGHT?
YEAH, AND LOOK II
CAME OF AGE DURING THE
20-YEAR WINDOW BETWEEN THE
VINCE LOMBARDI,
PACKERS. AND THE MIKE HOLMGREN
PACKERS WHERE THE PACKERS
STUNK FOR MOST OF THAT PERIOD
FROM
SEVENTY TO NINETY TWO. AND
BUT THEY CLEARLY ARE THE CLASS
OF THAT DIVISION
TWENTY SIX AND SIX OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
AND I STILL THINK THAT EVEN IF
ROGERS DOESN'T PLAY THEY'LL
FIND A WAY TO MAKE IT WORK.
MATT, LAFLEUR'S A BETTER COACH
THAN I THINK, PEOPLE ARE
GIVING HIM CREDIT FOR
VETERAN, QUARTERBACKS AHEAD OF
ROOKIES ON THE DEPTH CHART,
ANDY DALTON
IN CHICAGO CAM NEWTON
ENGLAND, JIMMY, G IN SAN
FRANCISCO, WHICH DOESN'T
BELONG ON WHY?
HMM,
I THINK JIMMY G.
I THINK JIMMY HE DOESN'T
BELONG IN HERE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT JIMMY G OUT OF THAT
GROUP,
YOU WANT TO THROW IN THE
TRAIT, LANCE PART WHERE HE IS,
YOU KNOW, EVERYONE KIND OF
ADMITS THAT HE'S
A PROJECT IN THAT
THERE'S THE RAW TALENT IS
THERE,
BUT HE'S GOT TO. THEY'VE GOT
TO WORK IT THROUGH.
I THINK JIMMY G HAS A CHANCE
THAT IF HE PLAYS. WELL, HE'S
GOING TO PLAY THE ENTIRE YEAR.
I DON'T SEE ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE TO ANY
DALTON PLAYS THE ENTIRE YEAR
AND I THINK IT'S PRETTY
UNLIKELY. THE CAM NEWTON PLAYS
THE ENTIRE
YEAR
I'M GOING TO SAY CAM NEWTON
BECAUSE I THINK HE'S CLEARLY
THE BEST OF THE THREE. THE
QUESTION IS
HOW MUCH GAS IS IN THE TANK? I
THINK HE'S THE BEST OF THE
THREE. I THINK HE IS, I THINK
HE IS, I THINK LAST YEAR
THE COVID THING
MADE IT SEEM WORSE THAN IT WAS
THE LATE ARRIVAL IN NEW
ENGLAND, HE HAD A LOT TO LEARN
A LOT TO PROCESS. I THINK HE'S
GOING TO BE BETTER THIS YEAR.
NOW WHETHER HE HOLDS OFF, MATT
JONES IS A DIFFERENT ISSUE BUT
I THINK OF THE THREE
QUARTERBACKS, IF I HAD TO TAKE
ONE TO BE THE QUARTERBACK OF
MY TEAM, IT WOULD BE CAM
NEWTON. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
YEAR BEFORE? THAT
HE WAS INJURED?
WHAT ABOUT THE YEAR BEFORE?
OR THAT WAS HE GOOD? IT WAS HE
INJURED LIKE I
HAD A SHOW. HE PLAYED THROUGH
HER SHOULDER INJURY. IN
2018, 2019, HE HAD THE
FOOT INJURY THAT KNOCKED HIM
OUT IN
WEEK TWO. YOU GOT YOU GOT TO
MANAGE HIM, YOU CAN'T. HERE'S
THE PROBLEM. AND I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY HE'S
HAD SO MANY INJURIES.
WHEN YOU SEE THE GUY
HE IS,
GIANT, HE LOOKS
INDESTRUCTIBLE AND YOU GIVE
YOURSELF
INTO THE TEMPTATION TO RUN HIM
INTO THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE
AND AND LET HIM GET
PHYSICALLY ABUSED ON THE
FOOTBALL FIELD AND GUESS WHAT?
HE'S MADE
AT THE SAME STUFF. THE REST OF
US ARE MADE OF. THAT'S HOW
HE'S HAD SO MANY INJURY
ISSUES SO THERE'S NEVER BEEN.
I THINK A COACHING STAFF THAT
PROTECTS CAM NEWTON FROM
HIMSELF
BECAUSE I THINK HE BELIEVES IT
TOO,
I'M HE IS A GIANT
BUT HE'S JOKING. GET INJURED
LIKE ANYONE ELSE I'M JUST
LOOKING AT IT RIGHT NOW. I
MEAN, HE'S
JUST HASN'T BEEN
THE SAME GUY SINCE HIS MVP
YEAR,
HE'S BEEN,
YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A DECREASING VALUE OF
WHAT HE'S BEEN BUT I THAT'S
WHY I PUSH BACK ON
THE IDEA THAT LIKE, OH
COVID AND SHORT MINI CAMP LIKE
MAYBE THERE'S A CHANCE
THAT CAM NEWTON JUST ISN'T
GOOD ANYMORE. COULD THAT BE
A POSSIBLE RIDING BACK THERE?
BUT THEY BROUGHT HIM BACK.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE BROUGHT HIM
BACK.
IF THEY DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
ANY GOOD, THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
BROUGHT HIM BACK. I DON'T
REMEMBER THE THOUGHT THERE WAS
A REPORT AT ONE POINT. THEY
WEREN'T BRINGING HIM BACK AND
THEY BROUGHT HIM BACK.
OKAY,
II. JUST THINK THAT
JIMMY.
YOU KNOW, HE WAS, HE STILL HAD
A GOOD YEAR, THE YEAR, THEY
WENT TO THE SUPER BOWL,
HE GOT INJURED LAST YEAR.
THAT THING FELL APART
THEIR ROSTERS. STILL REALLY
GOOD. HE STILL HAS
GEORGE KID'LL. SO I
HOW SHANAHAN SYSTEM. I DON'T
KNOW, I JUST THINK JIMMY G
COULD GET A LITTLE HOT HERE
AND ESPECIALLY WITH A GUY LIKE
TRADE LANCE, WHO IS A PROJECT,
EVERYONE ADMITS THAT,
YOU CAN SEE HIM PLAYING THE
ENTIRE
YEAR.
AND
THAT MAKES THE WHOLE DECISION.
TO TRADE UP FROM 12, TO 3.
GIVE UP TO EXTRA
FIRST-ROUND PICKS, GIVE UP A
THIRD-ROUND PICK. HAVE THIS
MONTH-LONG MYSTERY OF. WHAT
ARE THEY GOING TO DO? I STILL
DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE 49ERS ARE THINKING
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
AFTERMATH
OF
THEIR ACKNOWLEDGE FAILURE
INTERNALLY
TO NOT DRAFT PAT MAHOMES
AND TO NOT TAKE, TOM,
BRADY UP ON HIS DESIRE TO COME
BE THE 49ERS QUARTERBACK
IN
2020. ALL RIGHT, ONE MORE REAL
QUICK, BEARS.
FIRST ROUND PICKS WHICH
DOESN'T BELONG IN WHY MITCHELL
TRUE BISCAY KEVIN WHITE. CADE
MCNOWN, WHICH DOESN'T
BELIEVE WHY.
OOH, YOU KNOW WHAT? MICHENER
BISCAY DOESN'T BELONG TO THAT
GROUP BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS EVERYONE MAKES FUN OF
MITCH STRABINSKY, THERE'S A
COUPLE LIKE JUST FACTS
THAT MAKES HIM NOT KEVIN
WHITE OR CAME
BACK DOWN,
GAMING DOWNPLAYED? YEAH, I
DON'T 15 GAMES. HE STARTED 20
YOU KNOW,
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHT. HE
WAS IN REMEMBER, THEY DID THE
LIKE HE WAS GOING IN A
SERIES HERE AND THERE SO HE
PLAYED
LET'S JUST SAY
DEFINITELY LESS THAN 30 GAMES
FOR THE BEARS, KEVIN WHITE
PLAYED A HANDFUL OF GAMES TO
THE BEARS,
MR. RISKY PLAYED FOUR SEASONS.
THEY WENT TO THE PLAYOFFS
TWICE LIKE HE HE
THE PROBLEM WITH MR. BISCAY IS
HE WAS DRAFTED IN FRONT OF
PATRICK MAHOMES AND DESHAUN
WATSON. KEVIN WHITE WASN'T
DRAFTED IN FRONT OF
AN ALL-TIME WIDE RECEIVER.
KEEPING NOW WASN'T DRAFTED IN
FRONT OF AN ALL-TIME
QUARTERBACK. LIKE DONOVAN
MCNABB WAS THE SECOND PICK IN
THAT DRAFT. SO
IT'S MR. BISCAY AS MUCH AS
EVERYONE PILES ON HIM,
HE SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
SAME CONVERSATION. IS THOSE
OTHER TWO GUYS?
YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT AND YOU
GET THEM IN THE RIGHT SYSTEM.
YOU GET THEM IN THE RIGHT
OFFENSE. YOU GET THEM ON THE
RIGHT TEAM. WITH THE RIGHT
COACH AND THERE'S STILL HOPE
TOSO METHING IN THE NFL. LET'S